3 2 avec mes potes on vient de la vallée
de san fernando
l'étendue plate qui se trouvent de
l'autre côté des collines d'hollywood
super d'acteurs de serveurs et de
futures stars n'ont pas les moyens de
vivre à l écoute et j'ai une idée je dis
aux socialistes sortir de l'île certains
être là
hier soir les deux tares life suit le dj
florence cassez faire danser les gens et
c'est la moitié qui aiment se trouve que
tu as du talent tu arriveras de parts en
utilisant les mêmes vieux sombre et tous
les autres
vous en mettre plein les poches direct
tu m'appelles t'as pas l'impression
qu'on pourrait faire mieux lors des
trucs vachement
artistique du succès ont vécu ce moment
où ils ont arrêté d'admirer les autres
pour trouver leur signature je crois que
je tiens
ça le meilleur roman c'est le moment
avant que ça commence un sacré paquet
girl hot
bah ouais c'est cool et carter